欢迎收听阿哈FM字栏目经验谈。
每期我们会邀请一位阿哈Club经验星球小程序上的前辈，
分享大学生球之干货。
听完如果想进一步找前辈模拟面试修改简历，
可以在小程序上找到谈。
欢迎大家来到阿哈FM，
然后今天我们邀请到的是我们阿哈小程序的导师Elly，
然后现在请我们的Elly做一下简单的自我介绍。
嗨，大家好，谢谢主持人。
那我叫Elly，我是本科是在一个211大学，
读的是仇文科是广告学，
然后是之后在大三大四的时候，
转而去在美国读的DF Science相关的Master，
那其实在我本科的时候没有什么拆明试习，
然后也没有什么太多细经经历，
但是备战了三个月以后，
成长拿到了京东和去哪儿往的拆明offer，
然后在美严毕业以后，
是脱离了国内的互联网环境，
插播了两年的时间情况下，
然后拿到了自己和shopping的sp，
然后包括美团和滴滴其他的，
大概小小10个左右的offer。
好的，好的，谢谢Elly，
Elly只是也是一个比较优秀，
而且看她的一个春秋照的情况，
其实是一个也算是over收割机，
然后那今天Elly给我们带来的内容，
主要围绕哪一些呢？
我主要还是想要去。
针对一些产品时期经历比较少，
或者是零基础的同学吧，
因为我也是这么一步步过来的，
然后主要也是想聊一下，
求职产品的一些基本功，
然后包括简历啊，和面试副盘之类的。
其实我比较好奇，
对于你来说，
所谓的求职的基本功，
它是有哪些内容呢？
我觉得求职的话，
我先说一下我的看法，
我觉得求职有点像高考，
就是如果说职论结果的话，
就高考有80%的基础分嘛，
然后如果说每一步都做得很好的话，
其实不会太差，
然后我觉得求职也是一样的，
如果说这个基本功做好了，
80%的offer也是有机会的，
所以第一个是觉得基本功还很有必要，
第二看流程的话，
我觉得高考也都是大家。
每一个人都先确定好了，
自己想要去的大学，
或者是文理科，
然后去进行知识的积累，
然后不断的模拟考，
不断的修订错题，
然后才可能信心慢慢走进高考，
那个考场嘛，
但是求职我觉得也是一样的，
你必须得先从自己过去的经验。
和学习中认识自己，
然后去定义自己，
然后我们才大概知道自己。
朝什么方向努力，
然后在这个情况下面，
我们去不断打磨自己的建立，
然后再包括各种面试和副排磨练自己，
然后最终才可能会在求职市场上面，
去反向选择offer，
所以我觉得个人觉得比较重要的节点，
第一个就是，
你在确定自己，
定义好自己的情况下，
去打磨好自己的简历，
然后第二个是面试和副排。
嗯,好,
其实我感觉，
Eddie应该对于自己的求职，
应该有很多的一些taps，
那我现在的话是比较希望，
Eddie能跟我们分享一下你的杀手剪，
那对于你来说，你的杀手剪是哪些呢？
我觉得我做的比较好的，
第一个是简历上面的铁带很快，
我的简历铁带很快，
基本上都完全取决于我关键词，
就我有一个自己比较完整的关键词库，
这是简历上面的。
第二个的话，
我觉得应该是简历上的圣蛙，
就是简历上的圣蛙，
我可以到就是，
面试关去圣蛙我的简历，
我基本上都能够回答出来，
而且我基本上能够感受到，
他应该可能会问什么，
我都会准备的很好，对，
就基本上一面的简历，简历关，
基本上是不会有太大问题的。
明白，那除了简历上的关键字盒，
对于自己简历的圣蛙，
还有其他的一些点吗？
嗯，我觉得在，
呃，面试准备上面吧，
我会，呃，
也有一个自己比较完整的一个，
面试的一个提库，
然后这个提库的话，
会根据我面的不同的公司，
去做不同的，呃，
就是素材的一些，
积累和分析，
然后再包括最后的副盘，
对，其实我有一个，
专门的一个notion的一个库，
然后每一个公司的，
每一个就是我面过的产品，
我基本上都有一个完整的一套的，
就准备方案，
明白，明白，
艾利这边围绕两个方面，
分享了四个点嘛，那我们先来，
也欢迎艾利给我们分享一下，
就是你的一些，具体的一些小点，
比如说，呃，
我们可以先从你最开始提到的简历的关键字来，
呃，展开，就是说，
你觉得，呃，所谓的简历关键字，
它意味着什么，
然后大家怎么样去把握这个点？
嗯，行，那对于关键词的话，
我觉得，它意味着什么，
就是，它是否能给你求值的这个方向，
比较 match?。
这个其实是比较重要的，
第二个其实在于，
呃，比如说你已经过了简历关，
但是在面试的时候，
面试关基本上是没有太多的时间。
去提前看你的简历的，
或者是，它根本就没有那个时间。
去好好地去过你的简历，
这个时候，关键词其实是更好的，
去能够概括你一段经历的，
一个关键的一个地方，
然后也经常是一个面试关的切入点，
然后对于我来说的话，
我做关键词的话，
我基本上都会，
使人第一步是把我的经历给列出来，
就是我到底一份实习里面有多少。
细节上面的一些经历，
我把列出来以后，我会把它去，
呃，去做一些关键词的提取，
比如说我自己认为，
它可能是属于哪些关键词，
是数据分析啊，或者是。
用户分析运营啊，
或者是用户路径的一个优化，
我都会去把它去做好，
这个时候其实我相信大家都会发现，
就是你一段经历，
它是可以有不同的关键词的，
呃，然后这个期也没有关系，
你就把一段经历放多个关键词，
然后这个时候我就会去找，
比如说我当时，
目标是策略PM，
我会把就是，像自己啊，
然后腾讯啊，或者是各种各样。
大厂的策略PM的JD拿下来，
我会去找对应的关键词，
比如说在经历上面，
他们很可能就需要的是数据分析，
然后对指标的定义，
那对于比如说硬性标准上面，
他们会要求你用SQL，
这样的一些能力，
其实这个关键词是非常重要的，
然后你再去把这些关键词，
和你的经历去进行一个match，
这个时候你的这个经历，
会去到一个，怎么说呢，
就更加关键呢，
或者是更加符合他们JD标准的一个关键词，
然后在这样的时候，
你在放上去的时候，
然后也更加会让你的经历，
和这个求职方向，
会更加贴合，
首先就是你对于自己的经历，
会做关键词的拆解，
然后的话就会对目标的企业的JD，
进行关键词的拆解，
然后去做两边的一个匹配，
然后帮助你去，
让自己的减力更符合他们的要求，
是不是大概是这样一个流程，
是的，然后其实关键词还有一个好处，
这个是你出创这个你的减力吗，
但是到后面的时候有可能，
特别是对于一些零经验的同学，
他可能会转变自己的方向，
比如说，从策略转向用户，
其实这个也是没有关系的，
是因为，
首先你自己的一些经历里面，
词库都已经有了，
就是比如说，
你应用数据分析的能力，
去做这个用户的一个，
路径行为分析，
或者是去提高这个用户的一个转化，
其实这个去可以分出来很多的方向的，
比如说用户分析，用户运营和数据分析，
那你可以去提取的，
比如说你要转向用户了，
用户产品了，
那你就可以用用户分析，
或者是用户运营，
去做这样的关键词，
这个时候对你来说，
你去迭代你的减力是会更快的。
明白，其实这有点像搭机幕的感觉，
就是你去把所有的东西都拆成了很小的零件，
你去把它搭成，
就是你想要的以及目标公司想要的样子，
这样的话就是更快捷，
然后也能造出更好的一些，
更符合目标的一些减力来，
对，感觉有那么一点点意思。
对，除了关键词的话，
其实还说了一些你的一些生蛙的减力，对吧，
那你是怎么去做到生蛙减力，
以及把生蛙减力，
就是展现给别人，
甚至在面试中可能也会用到呢？
我觉得，
首先第一个展现的话，
其实我自己会有自己比较完善的github，
然后这个github其实会放我所有的东西，
就比如说我之前是做数据分析嘛，
我会把我所有的数据项目都放在github里面，
然后其实用，
然后上面后面会贴一个朝链接，
然后这样的话，
其实大家去点到的时候，
会可以到我整个的所有的一个数据项目，
然后也能看到我个人那个成长，
然后到后面的时候，
我刚才打我的很多产品方面的，
包括我当时的一些创业项目，
全部都放在里面了，
然后这个其实是可以凸显出来，
就是我自己是有成电的，
然后我自己是有成长的，
那我这些项目也是能够被你们看得到的，
而不是仅仅就是文字的描述，
然后这是一方面，
另外一方面的话，
其实就是文字方面了，
文字方面的话，
我其实建议大家，
也是老生常谈的一个东西吧，
就是简历上写出来的重点，
应该是做了什么，成果如何，
但是你写的时候要想，
你讲，应该怎么讲，
因为你讲了重点，
应该是为什么做，
然后你做的结果如何，
就是这个可能是两方面是要去考虑的，
就是第一个方面你在微观上面，
是需要去对你简历上的每个字要负责的，
比如说你讲你为什么做，
你甚至都可以问自己说，
比如说这里有个指标，
然后这个指标它上升了，
但是这个指标真的能代表你这个方案是成功的吗，
如果说这个指标不是，
那当时为什么只能用这样的一个指标呢，
然后这个指标的局限又在哪里，
你觉得又可以做什么样的改进，
比如说你成长到现在了，
你在看之前的一些经历，
你觉得这个指标能做什么改进，
如果是现在你应该会怎么做，
其实这个是你自己要先想到的，
然后以防到时候，
面试官他可能真的深挖到这一步，
你没有办法去回答，
然后也包括举我一个例子吧，
就是当时我在简历里面写了，
一段经历里面我用数据分析，
我用了两个方式，
一个是Go Analytics,。
一个是Mix Panel,。
然后这个其实当时我自己就有问自己说，
为什么用两个产品，
然后同样都是做数据分析，
然后到后面的时候，
我当时其实自己没想明白，
但在后面的时候，
我自己去深挖的时候去发现，
原来Go Analytics,。
它的用途是让我去看，
流量的进来的时候，
从哪个渠道进来，
它能转化率如何，
但是Mix Panel对我来说，
更重要的是看，
用户在我们这产品上的使用路径如何，
然后这跟结底的原因，
其实是在于，
他们的那个指标维度是不一样的，
那这个时候，
其实到时候，
面试官再来问我的时候，
最后确实也问了我这样的问题，
我就能很好的回答他，
甚至我们引出了后面的问题，
就是Go Analytics和Mix Panel,。
它的区别到底在哪里，
他们有什么的优势，
然后也发表了我自己对于。
这两个产品的看法，
然后我觉得，
这个其实是大家在深挖的时候，
会越来越惊喜，
就会发现原来你想了这么多，
然后原来你还可以发展到。
这样的一个方向上面去，
所以我觉得，
这个其实大家可以去考虑的，
就是自己去问，自己去答，
然后更多的问自己为什么，
然后还有一个方面的话，
我觉得是在简历上的宏观上面吧，
你要在宏观上知道自己做了什么，
能带来什么影响，
又有什么局限，
那比如说，你作为一个实习生，
可能一直都是免太推热你走的，
去做一些比较瑣碎的事情，
但是有没有思考过，
说我们这整个团队的okel是什么呢，
然后我在这个团队里面，
是什么样的角色，
我做的这些东西，
对okel有什么样的贡献，
我觉得这个是可以考虑的，
那一只看，
就是你做这个东西对女的mental来说，
okel是什么样的一个影响，
对于整个团队的一个大方向来说，
又是什么样的影响，
这个其实是自己可以去慢慢去思考的，
然后还有另外一个例子的话，
可能是，就比如说你做了一个项目，
那这个项目它到底为什么能成，
它又为什么不能成，
这次也是一个比较宏观上面的问题，
但是经常会被问到，
那比如说当时我做了一个求职社区，
然后这是一个创业项目，
它拿到了奖，
但是实际应用中却失败了，
然后我写在了简历里面，
就经常会被面试官去问，
说你这个创业项目竟然成功了，
那为什么没有继续做下去，
然后这个时候，
我就根据我对于求职社区的方向，
去进行一些比较宏观方面的解答，
比如说我对于这个市场的认知，
那对于用户的一些认知，
比如说这个市场它其实是波动的，
它每次在春招和秋招的时候，
用户量会几句的增大，
但是它并不能维持，
然后包括用户这方面，
每年其实都是新的用户，
每年老的用户它其实不能留存的，
因为它拿到offer它就会走了，
你怎么要去留存它，
其实这上面都花了很大的时间成本，
和人力成本，
然后包括金钱成本，
那这个其实就代表我们这个东西，
它可能会有用，
但是利益方面的话，
我们有办法会来更多的利益，
所以我觉得，
如果说大家能够去想到，
说宏观上面这个东西，
它到底能不能成有什么样的影响，
为什么会成这样的影响，
会让自己在简历这一关的时候，
会更加发亮，
然后更加出彩一些。
明白，听下来的话，
其实就是两个东西，
第一个是关于你自己的成长，
第二个是关于你所做的事情，
对于组织，
或者是你的创业项目的利益，
就是价值点在哪里，
那在自我成长里面的话，
它分成了横向和重向，
那横向的话，
就是你会把所有的项目都进行，
相关的记录，
然后重向的话，
你会给自己一个成长的，
那种里程碑的是，
那种感觉就是你把不同的项目，
按照时间段，
然后你也会去想，
这个项目结束之后，
那我对于前一个项目，
那我是否有一些成长，
然后在整一个记录的过程中，
你又会很注意一些细节上的东西，
比如说，
你说了自己对于两个模型的思考，
其实我觉得对于面试官来说，
他也很愿意听到你说这两项东西，
第一个是你自己的成长嘛，
因为当他发现你的成长的时候，
包括你对于一些事情的思考，
他都会觉得你可能是一个比较有可塑性的人，
他也会更愿意去，
有这样的人，
成为他们团队的一员，
然后我觉得第二点，
因为他们会希望就是，
团队里的每一员，
都是能为组织带来价值并且，
他们会主动的去思考自己的价值点在哪里，
从而去更好的为他们创造价值。
是的,
我觉得是，
我的面试官到后面给我形容是如此可笑。
就是,
其实我觉得，
重点不是在于你做的东西做错了什么，
而是在于你做这个东西失败了以后，
你得到了什么，
然后这个能反复给你什么，
因此成长成为什么样子，
或者你获得了什么样的成长，
这个其实更重要，
也是面试官他更想知道的，
因为其实大家都懂，
你不可能一直都成功，
你肯定有失败的时候，
产品经历里面，
迭代确实是很重要的一件事情，
如果说你能长期的自我迭代，
那确实能凸显出来，
你是具有，
就是成为产品经理这个特质的人。
对,
我之前听到一句话叫是，
像迭代产品一样去迭代自己，
就是你不断的去杀心自己，
让自己成为更好的人，
就像不断的去迭代产品，
然后去让产品成为更好的产品。
对，做自己的产品经理。
做产品，教你做人。
对,
其实说实话，
你这些其实简历里面，
其实你也有很多东西，
是要反映在面试里面的吧，
比如说你刚才举了那个例子，
就是两个工具，
它是,
就是两个工具的思考，
最终会反映到面试里面嘛，
那其实你刚才也有讲过你的，
嗯,
面试的tep，
最大我们可以讲，
就是你关于面试的一些准备，
或者是思考。
嗯，可以啊，
我觉得面试的话，
我只要分两部分吧，
一个是面试准备，
另外一个是副盘，
就面试过程中呢，
我觉得我也不用太多说了，
大家其实都懂，
然后面巾上也有很多，
我主要就说一下，
面试准备这一块，
嗯,
其实我觉得我会分两种不同的人吧，
就第一种的话，
可能是相关经历比较丰富的人，
然后这种人的话，
其实简历会非常非常丰富，
其实,
就面试官会被简历上的，
简历上的一些经历给吸引走，
所以这个时候，
简历的把握会更加重要，
然后更需要对简历上的每个字负责，
然后对于就是简历，
相关经历不足的人来说，
我可能会更加照顾这一类的同学，
我就会多给一些建议吧，
就第一个是，
我觉得场外的基础问题，
一定要准备全面，
比如说比较基础的那种行为问题，
你为什么适合做一个产品经理，
你觉得你有哪些特质，
能做好一个产品经理，
我觉得这种问题是你一定要准备好的，
因为面试官他没有什么地方，
就是你简历当中去切入一个点，
去来问你，
他就会问一些，
第一个是基础问题，
第二个就是你产品的相关一些问题，
然后比如说像产品方向的一些问题的话，
因为你没有产品经理，
他就会问一些，
就是大家可能都会问到的，
比如说你有没有喜欢的产品，
就这种问题，
我觉得大家也是需要准备的，
像我当时准备的话，
我会根据，
比如说我当时在面美团，
我就会把美团的相关的产品，
和饿了吗，
进行一个对比，
然后包括他现在在做的买菜，
我去跟人家想，
钱大妈呀，
或者其他的一些产品进行对比，
然后从各方面伪度去对比了以后，
其实你在去面试公司，
你会有更多的一些底气，
然后包括大家会问你说，
你对美团这个产品怎么看，
你也有更多的空间，
然后去跟面试官去聊，
然后包括说，
基础问题，
其实你要根据你的这个面试的一个方向，
去进行准备，
比如说功能型和用户型，
看可能问的更多的就是，
你有没有喜欢的产品，
你对这个产品有没有什么见解，
有没有什么，
就值得改进的地方，
但是如果说是商业和数据产品经历，
那可能又不一样了，
那可能商业就会问你说，
你觉得某某产品有什么样的变现模式，
那你能不能打出来，
比较基本的变现模式，
比如说广告，
比如说像会员，
那这些你能否打出来，
然后你是不是能分析说，
这种变现模式，
它的不一样的地方，
和它的好处和优点和劣势，
那再比如说像数据产品经历，
它可能会问你说，
你觉得什么样的数据能帮助我们判断，
做什么事情是否是成功的，
那比如说，
更细化一点的，
比如说是做用户留存的，
是做商业化的一些数据的，
你是不是知道LTV是什么，
ARPU是什么，
留存是什么，
然后你是否能够去拆解出来，
这样的一套公式，
它到底每一个数据到底代表的是什么意思，
然后再包括比如说广告投放，
那你知道广告投放的指标是什么吗？
然后比如说像CPC和CPA的区别，
你知道是什么吗？
其实我觉得更多的，
第一个就是你准备一些。
比较大而全的技术问题，
那种有没有喜欢的产品，
你是否能做好一个产品经历，
那第二个就是，
你自己去看，
就是面经当中，
跟你比较匹配的那种，
你要求这个方向，
它的一些问题到底是真的哪些方向的，
然后有必要的时候，
确实需要去看一些相关的数据，
对,
然后还有一个tip，
其实就是，
当你准备那些问题的时候，
你也可以发现，
自己对哪类问题更擅长，
更适合自己，
这个其实也能更好的，
是帮助你去定义你自己，
明白,
其实我就感觉，
就像你是为自己的简历拆，
那个关键字一样，
其实你在做面试准备的时候，
你也是会根据
你面试的对象，
然后去做一些相应的准备，
比如说你会去做产品分析，
然后比如说你会去做一些。
颗外的一些数据分析，
指标的一些学习，
就在我看来，
就是你的面试准备，
就是围绕产品，
就是产品需要做什么，
然后去针对于你，
你的一个面试的公司，
去做相应的准备，
大概是不是就是这样，
我觉得你很好的
概括了我这个人，
就是拆解，
就是我感觉，
其实就是发现问题，
解决问题嘛，
就是最基本的，
就是你发现自己有什么欠缺的，
发现你跟这个还差距有多少，
然后你去进行解决，
然后对应的就可以去拆解了。
对于你来说，
副盘,
它的关键在于哪里呢？
关键在于高效，
因为其实，
比如说你在穿上过秋招的时候，
你时间是安排得很紧的，
你可能一个面完了，
就接着面下一个了，
你时间有限，
到底你能不能副盘都是一个问题，
所以怎么样去值得高效副盘，
我觉得这个还蛮重要的，
那对于我来说的话，
我觉得，
首先你需要定义什么值得副盘，
并不是说，
面试官问你的每一个问题，
你都需要去记录下来，
然后去反思的，
我觉得问题，
需要记录问题有两个，
一个是新的问题，
一个是有价值的问题，
新的问题，
就像我之前说的就是，
你可能准备了一部分问题，
但是呢，
可能有可能面试的时候，
你会问到一些，
你没有准备到的，
或者是你在，
就是,
你根本就没有想到过的一些问题，
这种新的问题，
是确实是值得好好准备的，
然后第二个是有价值的问题，
这个有价值的问题在于，
他问了这个问题，
你没有办法回答的，
符合自己的预期，
或者是你也表现，
你能很有，
很明显的感受到，
面试官并不满意，
我觉得这种问题，
其实你可以放到，
比如说面试之后，
到时候面试官问你，
有还有什么问题要问他的时候，
你可以着重去问这个问题，
就是,
你为什么要问这个问题，
或者是，
你希望得到什么样的回答，
然后这样的话，
其实可以对你有更好的反馈，
然后你自己副盘的时候，
也需要去着重于，
对这种问题进行深挖，
然后,
还有一个的话，
我觉得副盘也并不是说，
单纯的去列出，
大家问了什么，
然后你回答了什么，
可能重点更在于，
面试官为什么问这个问题，
他是,
是你之前的回答有漏洞，
所以说面试官问了一个fallout，
还是说，
你没有展示自己展示完前，
所以说面试官需要你进一步的展示自己，
所以去问了一个补充性的问题，
然后,
我觉得这些企业是，
大家可以去，
想象自己是一个面试官，
然后去想象，
可能这个进行到哪一步了，
那下面一个step是什么，
然后也包括，
比如说我问出了这个问题，
我到底希望听到的是什么样的答案，
就按照面试官的思维来去走的话，
这样的一个副盘我就会更高消息，
就是以面试官的角度，
其实你也可能就是会更加开阔一点，
你可能考虑的并不仅仅就是产品这方面，
你可能也会考虑到人力啊，
然后资源啊，
这一系列，
其实当你换一个角度，
你就,
就思维就打开了，
然后你也会考虑的更加全面，
那你会不会是有选择的，
针对某几场面试去做那种副盘呢？
哦，这个也会的，
我先说一下我之前的面试吧，
我都会有个时间规划，
我会把我觉得应该冲刺的，
就是，就是岗位放在中期，
然后前期的时候，
我会尽可能的尝试自己，
因为我不知道我在纠约市场上，
是个什么样的位置，
所以我经常就会去面一些，
比如说大厂的实习，
或者是，
就是日常实习嘛，
或者是一些小厂的一些权质，
然后在面这种时候，
就是一开始的时候，
我真的会副盘很多，
因为每次都会发现有新问题，
我没有记下来的，
或者是我根本就没准备的，
但是到后期慢慢慢慢的，
我只会挑一些我比较看重的一些公司的，
或者是我觉得这个面试。
比较重要的一些的去进行副盘啊，
因为在前期我记了那么多，
到后面的时候基本上都用上了，
然后也表现的会让我觉得还比较满意，
对。
那你在这些地方里面，
有没有其他要补充的？
你要说有什么建议的话，
其实我会建议大家放平心态，
就是我放平心态基本上都是，
哇，这个面试我又可以面到大佬了，
就是在我看来，
你是很难去接触到很多大佬的，
呃，面试是一个非常好的机会，
你可以去认识很多大佬，
然后，呃，在这样的一个情况下面，
其实你可以去问，
就是你去放平心态，
就当做去跟他学习，去跟他交流，
然后你就不会那么紧张，
就经常有面试完价着我的时候，
我就想，哇，原来他还有这个思路，
真太好了，我要记下来，
对，而反而不会说感到紧张，
如果说紧张，
你是因为太在乎你能不能得到这个岗位了，
但是如果你把重心放在，
你能不能在这个面试中获得什么，
那我觉得会更重要一些，
呃，其实我当时是面了有几家小公司或中场了，
然后面下得特别特别好，
到后面的时候，
我跟面试官就是一直保持联系到现在，
我觉得这个真的是很宝贵的一个财富，
就是，其实面试官也能感受到。
你到底是一个什么样的状态去面的，
如果说你确实是带着思考，
或者是带着问题去面他的，
他真的会给你解答好多。
其实我觉得这个心态还不错，
就是你把每一次面试都做成是双向选择，
是，我觉得这个挺重要的，
特别是全职的时候，
确实要考虑很多东西，
而并不仅仅是说，
能够交一个满分打卷就没了，
因为你也要给别人打分，
对，其实就是双向选择。
就我们会强调每次求职都是双向选择，
对，虽然其实到最后，
求职者可能会处于劣势，
但是当我们以双向选择这个心态去做准备，
或者是应对面试的时候，
可能你的心态会更轻松一点，
然后面试官也会更欣赏你这种，
不拘调的一种表现。
对，我觉得是，
而且有些时候我把它归于玄学，
就是这个我没面上也没关系，
可能是缘分没道，
对，这样可能会好一点。
对，有可能。
因为你也不知道，
就是面试官是什么状态，
他可能就也没有准备好，对。
好，你被杀掉了，你可以想，
可能就是因为气场不合吧，
就算我吃工作了，
我可能也不一定能跟他气场合起来。
对对对，这个也很重要，
我觉得，
因为尤其是像自己的美团嘛，
你可能面的第一个人，
或第二个人就是你面试，
确实要考虑这个问题，
就是能合得了是真的很重要的，
就我当时还问了一个人说，
我觉得大家都在往大厂走，
但是我也不知道大厂到底适不适合我，
就他可能适合很多人，
适合大部分人，
但是我并不知道这适不适合我，
然后我就跟面试官聊了好久这个事情，
然后真的当时就会让我觉得大受正开，
然后也学到了很多东西吧，
所以我觉得其实是很多问题，
就是你只要思考了，
然后你去问，
就真的，
大家会很愿意会答你？
可以,
其实我觉得无论是面试官，
还是被面试的人，
其实都还挺在意这一点的，
其实你也会更想要一个，
会思考的一个工作范围吧，
因为你，
其实当你自己是一个比较会思考的人，
其实,
思考的本质就是想要把这件事情做得更好嘛，
如果你自己本身是一个比较爱思考的人，
你也会希望在一个爱思考的团队里面，
对,
我感觉是这样子。
嗯,
而且还有一个方法建议大家不要太紧张，
就是,
面试官有可能比你还要紧张。
哦,
我记得我之前就有一次面试，
就是太紧张了，
其实面试官是听到了我的紧张，
然后我最后说，
最后我面试官有没有什么建议，
他就说你最开始太紧张了，
然后后面才好起来，
因为当时那场面试面试有一个多小时嘛，
然后是后面半段，
然后我才慢慢的，
就是进入状态，
然后前面就很紧张，
对,
因为我当时突然打电话，
然后你就，
突然就，
啊,
这是一场面，
这是一场阿里的面试，
哦,
你在说什么，
我就一脸问逼，
对,
然后就开始进入面试，
其实,
就很突击，
嗯,
所以说明，
阿里有多绝，
对,
太紧了，
那如果，
我们今天也可以，
继续的参与我们这个活动，
对,
因为我觉得可能，
现在只是秋之嘛，
以后可能工作了之后，
还会有其他的一些，
呃,
工作经验的一些分享，
也欢迎继续做课，
我们的栏目，
嗯,
好呀,
那当然了，
感谢阿里今天的分享，
那我们今天的分享，
就到此结束啦，